talk about crowds knowledge of the crowd
as sort of an organizing principle for
this talk but I think you know a lot of
it is motivated by thinking about
Duncan's comments on problems and
problem oriented social science and I
think you know it is a little bit heroic
here in a sense it's it's a little bit
like herding cats you know social
scientists do what they want to do and a
lot of the talks will be a little bit of
what we do but but reoriented a bit in
in the direction of problem solving and
I I want to throw out problems of
different levels that I think are
important and I'll ground this talk in
narrower ones but but the overall
motivating process is really sort of
thinking about reducing what I put it
here quotes bad inequality so there's a
lot of inequality in the world we're
seeing changes in it we're seeing it
documented it's it's something which is
problematic and I put bad in quotes
because there are certain elements of it
which are going to be incidental and
part of any system and there's other
parts which are really fundamentally
handicapping and hurt world welfare and
efficiency and those are the ones we
want to identify and eradicate in some
ways and what I'm going to talk about
it's really two more specific problems
that fall into this big umbrella one is
increasing accessibility to microfinance
and that was a very specific problem so
essentially what i'm going to do is give
a vignette of what Duncan was talking
about where we started with a very
specific problem that we needed to solve
we went in we analyzed it we built some
theory and we have a suggested solution
and we've tested the solution and it
seems to be working so it's going to be
sort of here's the problem here's how we
thought about it here's what we
understood from the theory here is our
suggested solution and and now we just a
report on some test we've just been
finishing in the last year or two and it
seems to be working so this has been
about a 10-year project very large scale
in terms of funding but very small scale
in terms of these
kinds of you know overarching social
problems the second one is more
grandiose in terms of its overarching
problem and a much smaller slice but I
think both of these tie together in a
sense that the solutions are going to
come from understanding what individual
people know about other people and this
is going to tie in a little bit I think
with what Michael Kern's will talk about
later on which is you know understanding
what people know about other people
crowd sourcing I'm having people solve
problems and in particular solving these
problems is going to involve
understanding what people know about
other people so in particular in
microfinance we're going to be looking
at diffusion processes and we want to be
able to identify people who are really
good diffusers in a population for
getting information out and we're going
to have to rely on the community's
knowledge of itself in order to identify
those people and so the question is how
do we identify those people and and how
are people able to do that in
understanding come awfully is going to
be a question of how good are people at
predicting other people's behaviors and
why might we see people segregating it
within a society and how do we
understand that segregation and and what
is that what are the implications
brought more broadly for for inequality
okay so I'm going to sort of break this
into pieces and this idea of what people
know about their social surroundings is
one that has some interesting sort of
conflicting perspectives one is that
that people actually navigate networks
remarkably well and we've seen that
going back to Stanley Milgram's famous
experiment of diffusing or getting
letters from individuals to targets jon
kleinberg has work on this duncan has
work doing this with emails and so forth
so so people actually navigate networks
relatively well but they have lousy
knowledge actually if their networks so
if you ask people to to name who their
friends friends are they can name their
friends friends who are actually their
own friends so I know my own friends and
i can tell you which of them are
connected with each other but i'm not
that good at naming who my friends
friends are and once you
go out more than two steps people are
essentially no better than random at
doing this so this is work by Noah
Friedkin David crack hard so there's a
series of things that sort of map out
that people don't have good social
knowledge but yet they they're going to
turn out to be very good predictors of
influence and position of others and
that's going to help us solve a problem
of actually getting information out so
we'll be using the population itself to
tell us who to talk to and then use that
information to pass the information
along the other thing is that they'll
actually be good predictors of each
other's behaviors but they're only going
to be good predictors of each other's
behaviors to the extent that the other
people look a lot like them so I'll
report on some some online experiments
that we've been using done
cross-culturally in India in the US and
and show you that that people in the US
are very good at predicting how people
in the US are going to play people in
India are good at predicting how people
in India are going to play but they
don't play well across and they play
very differently so surprisingly
differently they're going to they're
going to behave differently in a very
innocuous sort of symmetric game so
it'll be a fairly simple environment and
they're going to behave predictably
differently and they won't match well up
against each other okay so these are
online and field experiments mainly and
in here we're going to be trying to
understand whether or not people can
tell us things about each other and let
me start with this first part which is
the long-term project this is a
basically now a decade old or decade
ongoing so this work with a BG Banerjee
Arun undersea Karan Esther Duflo we've
been working in southern India and
trying to understand how to defuse
microfinance so that was the basic
problem that we started with and we
needed to identify influential people in
order to do this and I put here not just
popular people so there's a feeling that
somehow you know when there's something
which is known as the friendship paradox
if you want to find people who are
really popular in a network ask people
to name their friends and those are
going to be well-connected people so do
snowball sampling
here that turns out not to be the right
answer we don't want people who are just
popular we want people who are central
in a very specific sense and those are
going to be the people who are best for
diffusing so I'll first of all tell you
how those people are central and then
what we're going to have to do is
actually rely on people to identify
those individuals and I'm going to give
you some theory as to how they might be
able to do that and and then actually
show you that they that this actually
works so let me give you some sort of
background on the overall project so you
understand why we were doing this and
what the problem really was so this is
all in Karnataka roughly 100 to 200
kilometers of band around bangalore
there's we were working in relatively
poor villages so these are rural
villages typical villages about a
thousand people 200 households and the
villages are agricultural some dairy
production relatively poor about a
dollar per capita income and the problem
was the following so they're
microfinance organizations entering
these villages they're trying to get
microfinance products out so these are
small loans that are non secured loans
that are very productive and useful for
the population and the problem that they
were facing is they would go into some
villages and get nobody to take up they
were going other villages and get
substantial take up so they were getting
wide variation and these had been
identified as more or less identical
villages from the bank's perspective so
that you're getting very similar banks
but sorry villages but very different
outcomes and the question is sort of why
is that happening and could they improve
the outcomes so is there a way for them
to go in and actually make sure that the
microfinance is getting out to the
people who need it in these villages and
so the the first part was you know sort
of identifying why they were having this
problem and they were getting news out
by word of mouth and so it turns out
that the centrality of the first people
that they talked to in these villages is
a substantial predictor of whether or
not they get things out and so they had
a particular way in which they tried to
identify
people but it turns out that they
weren't that good at doing it and the if
they happen to hit central people in a
village things would take off but not
otherwise so then the real problem was
well how can they find central points
without network knowledge so we want it
went in and actually mapped out networks
but that's very expensive the bank
doesn't want to do that on a regular
basis so how can they find the right
people to talk to without actually going
in and surveying villages and mapping
out social networks and collecting a lot
of data so the question is can we tell
them here's a recipe for for solving
this by finding the right people in the
village and and basically can people
tell us and I'll explain why that we
think they can tell us and how they that
actually works okay so we went into the
village this is a typical village you
know it's roughly 200 households the
individuals are the points here and we
mapped out the networks in the village
so we have asked him 13 different
questions who do you borrow from who
would you go to to borrow 50 rupees for
a day who do you go to temple with who
do you ask for advice who comes to you
to buy kerosene and rice borrow kerosene
rice who do you go to an emergency for
medical help so we had a lot of
information and then the kind of attract
over time was that you know they would
the bank would come in the bank's
algorithm for trying to diffuse
information was to to tell their
employees find the shopkeepers self-help
group leaders and teachers in the
village so they would go in find those
people might find several of these nodes
and then tell them to spread the
information and what was happening is in
some villages you know the teacher might
be out here in other villages that the
teacher was in this central position and
so the question is first of all you know
how do you measure centrality how do we
identify these individuals can the bank
do better than just looking for
self-help group leaders teachers and
shopkeepers and they deliberately stayed
away from politicians I won't go you
know the caste politics and so forth are
tricky here so there are reasons that
they were using these as the categories
they thought these would be well
connected people turns out they weren't
that well connected it was pretty noisy
so can we do better
said a clarifying question are the edges
here between households or individuals
so the edges are going to be between
individuals so we we surveyed so now we
have service about ninety four percent
of the adult population so anybody over
18 in these villages but what we're
going to do is aggregate thanks to the
household unit because households were
the ones that could actually take out
loans and so the diffusion process was
more or less than a household level but
you can treat the data either way you
can find all these data on my website if
you're interested
right so basically the the let me show
you what what the process is by also to
give you a theoretical process and then
explain why we're looking for central
people so the bank comes in and what
it's trying to do is say look we're a
bank we're going to want to get out
information about microfinance these are
relatively poor villages so there's not
people don't have internet connections
some of them have cell phones SMS it's
mostly spam so people don't pay
attention to messages you sent so it's
hard to get news out so they're doing it
by word of mouth so they go in they tell
somebody look where the bank tell your
friends that we're going to be back in
two weeks there's going to be a meeting
and then information spreads and then
some people show up and then take out
loans but the information doesn't
necessarily spread that well right and
so the idea would be let's think about a
diffusion process let's say a simple SI
process and let's define centrality by
just defining a diffusion process so
here's a simple let's suppose that
people talk to their friends with a
probability point five if I tell you
about microfinance you tell your friends
with each friend that you bump into in a
given time period and with a probability
point five and let's think this operates
for some number of periods so we can
have a diffusion centrality measure
which says how frequently do people talk
about this subject and how long will
they talk about it and so now we can
just simulate so here's a node that we
we pick out of our village we say if
this was the first node informed let's
simulate for four periods well they
happen to tell one of their two
neighbors in the first period this goes
on and so forth and then after four
periods they've told 13 people so we can
say okay well this node would be worth
13 in terms of diffusion possibilities
if this were the process if it's a
pretty pretty good spreading process and
it lasts for about four periods now in
our data p is actually going to turn out
to be about point two is a good measure
and and roughly three is going to work
out for microfinance but this you know
we give an idea so we'd have a number
for this node you could do another node
work it out and you'd get six people
knowing so now you know look if they can
find this node instead of this one
they're going to do twice as well in
terms of getting information out okay so
it's just a really simple way of
finding sensuality which is based on a
very specific diffusion process and you
can show that this centrality measure
actually when T is 1 this is just going
to be proportional to degree just
popularity as T goes to infinity this is
going to begin to look like I ghen
vector centrality if the P is high
enough so in it has relationships to cat
sponsored centrality so we have some
theorems on this but the centrality
measure is related to a series of other
ones and people have looked at things
like this before so there's a cascade
process by kempei Kleinberg and Tardos
there's other you know so this is a
sensible way to think about defusing and
and will use their centrality measure
okay so first of all if we look at the
microfinance participation in the
villages and just look at what predicts
it so these are just regressions of
microfinance and what is on the side
here is the centrality of the first
informed people that they talked to in a
village so we actually know the networks
we know who they talk to and we can see
what the microfinance outcomes were and
we can measure sort of what the
diffusion centrality of the different
individuals that they talk to is so we
measure that we can measure eigenvector
centrality you can measure degree
centrality closeness you know pick
whatever way you want to define
centrality and here you get a highly
significant relationship between
microfinance participation and diffusion
centrality so I mean I think the
important numbers are down here so what
percentage of the variation do you
explain by looking at these different
measures diffusion centrality actually
does much better than the others it's
not surprising it's a richer measure but
it has much better than the others at
predicting explaining the variation in
terms of what's going various like in
terms of what do you define as
participation in like
just the bottom sure sure sure so so
what we looked at the dependent variable
is microfinance participation in a
village so we have 75 different villages
we looked at so actually 43 I'm going to
use in this data set so these are 43 of
the ones that the bank had entered by
the time we stop this part of this study
so the dependent variable is what
percentage of the population in that
village ended up taking up microfinance
and then the independent variable here
would be diffusion centrality of the
first nodes that they talk to and then
the given specific criteria or what
taking oh so these covariates are just
we also control for how many households
are in a village whether you know what's
the percentage of people involved in
self-help group so we use some lasso
regressions to figure out what other
variables to put in sorry yaso
microfinance is a is a sir 15 years of
microfinance I know what it is what does
it need to take up in your study um to
participate in alone with this Bank so
so there was one bank that these
villages had not had a bank entering
before participate microfinance means
this person took out a loan that's
actually already participating with
British so as she is just that there
were self-help groups in these villages
already yes but I'm talking about formal
microfinance coming from a Grameen style
yeah yeah what our ages again and jizz
our edges are going to be in that two
households are connected in one of these
networks so for the purposes of we're
going to use the the union of all of
these networks for that for that
regression the network was based on
answers to all these questions that we
asked them who do you go to for advice
who do you borrow money from so this is
one village out of the 43 in that
dataset this is the advice question this
is the temple question we'll put two
households to be linked together if they
answered yes on every and any household
or any question that's roughly degree
about 15 for a household out of about
220 households in the data set so
they're talking to about 1 15th of the
other households on average
in the data set we're looking at so it
looks denser in these graphs but it's
actually a fairly sparse graph when you
really get down to it okay so so what we
have is that diffusion centrality
predicts microfinance I ghen vector
centrality is also a reasonable
predictor I convector centrality is
running diffusion centrality off too
many periods so it seems that this is
actually a diffusion process at last
people talk a few times but don't talk
with 40 equals infinity okay so now the
problem is we want to solve this for the
bank the bank's getting lousy results
sometimes they're getting good numbers
sometimes they're getting bad numbers
they want to reduce that variance they
don't want to go through and did what we
did which is map out these networks and
then ask everybody and then find the
central people they want to find
essential people otherwise so the
question was could we just ask people
just ask them and obviously we're not
going to ask them who's the most
eigenvector central or diffusion central
person in your village but we could ask
them how would you actually you know who
should we talk to to diffuse information
and so that's what we did we just went
in we asked adults in the villages who
are the best people to start diffusion
and then we'll try and see what happens
so the questions we asked in particular
were if we want to spread information
about a new loan product to everybody in
your village who should we speak and
then we also asked if we want to spread
information to everybody in your village
about a music event drama or fair who
should we speak and we wanted to ask two
questions to make sure that they weren't
answering differently when they thought
it's a financial product that might be
exclusive exclusive versus something
just about a music event or fear that
was going on it turns out that the the
data are almost identical for these so
we're not going to i'm not going to show
you that both them or less identical
okay so first of all these are looking
at look in a given village ask how often
a particular household is nominated by
other people so how often does a
household point to this household and
then look at what the diffusion
centrality is so this is just a
diffusion centrality against how many
how often you're nominated okay so not
surprisingly the ones that are getting
very high numbers of nominations in some
cases they were named by almost
everybody in the villa
are highly central so you get a positive
relationship between the diffusion
centrality and whether or not people are
nominating the given individual
conditional on being nominated the
median number of times being nominated
as nine so a lot of times they're naming
the same household and they seem to be
naming people who are highly central and
you can sort of look at you know this
sort of breaks things down by saying
okay what share of people were both
nominated and have leadership status so
in the our self help group leaders
shopkeepers or teachers so if you look
at those the people who are nominated
and leader what's the probability that
they're in the top ten percentile of
sensuality and roughly there's almost a
fifty percent chance that they're in the
top ten percentile if they're nominated
not a leader that goes down to about
twenty-five percent if they're a leader
but not nominated then that's down to
about eighteen percent and if they're
not nominated not a leader then there's
about a ten percent chance that they're
in the top ten percent so they're little
worse than ten percent so basically you
know they're picking out individuals who
are highly central and they're doing it
much better than the bank would have
done alone and if we put together
leadership some demographics plus the
their nominations then we're able to
find the people who are I li central so
it doesn't take us long to find people
especially if we start looking for
people that are nominated multiple times
okay so just a quick theory I spend a
minute or two on this so how is it that
people are actually able to to do this
so why why would this actually work so I
told you before that people can't really
map out their networks they can't tell
you who which of your friends are who
are your friends friends so how are they
able to pick out people who are highly
central that often to two or three steps
away from them so the idea here is just
gossip so imagine that there's
information spreading through the
network by the same kind of process that
the diffusion process worked by its
what's going to happen is people are
just going to get information
periodically move to Stanford man has a
new
okay Esther won an award so this kind of
information is spreading about nodes and
I just keep track in my mind of the
overtime i just keep track of how often
I've heard about Esther how often have
heard about a ruin mat and so forth so I
just have this mental thing this is a
person I hear about all the time and
what I do is I infer that person must be
highly central because otherwise the
news couldn't have reached me in the
network so flip this upside down instead
of asking who's a good defuser now from
a listeners perspective how often do I
hear about different people that's going
to correlate with the diffusion and so
what you can show it's not hard to prove
a theorem which says that you take any
connected and a periodic network every
individual's hearing of others under
network gossip confused converges to
diffusion centrality as long as this
probability of talking is at least one
over the the first eigen value of this
matrix which is is non negative and
positive in this case and real and mt is
large enough so if people talk if you're
in this village long enough and you're a
listener then what's going to happen is
you'll be hearing things in proportion
to how central individuals are and so if
I just keep track of how often I hear
news coming from Duncan and philippson
on and from Michael and so forth then
eventually I'll be able to rank them in
terms of how good they are as spreaders
so so it's not hard to prove that um so
then what we did is say okay we can't
diffuse microfinance because we're not a
bank but what we could do is try a
different experiment and see whether the
people that are actually telling us
would be as good as just picking leaders
and and how well would it perform so
what we've done now is we went back in
just two years ago we've found 210
villages that weren't in our original
sample 70 of them what we did is we gave
away cell phones by randomly seeding the
villages just picking at random three or
five people to tell 70 what we did is we
looked for village elders or village
leaders within those villages and 70
what we did is we use the gossip so we
actually went in asked people who should
we use for diffusion and then use those
people three or five of those people for
diffusion
okay so we now we can look how well does
random work how well does you know using
some sort of leadership status work and
how well does using nominations work and
this is just a random seeds so each one
of these is uh is a village and then
this is the number of eventual cell
phones that we gave out and roughly you
know that there's reason there's one two
three four or five different numbers of
seeds sometimes we happen to hit all
five you know that we tried to find five
people all five were available sometimes
only four of them are available
sometimes only three and so forth so
there's a distribution of how many
initial points we had which just
depended on unavailability hear you ask
everybody or just small says no so we
picked 15 households so we asked 15
households and then out of there 15
nominations we randomly picked five or
three I mean depending on the treatment
yeah so this is what happens if you use
the leaders so the numbers are better so
the average is better but still not
great and then when you use the gossips
you know you get basically two to three
times what you got if you just use the
random or the leadership status so so
they're able to so they're telling us
people who are central and when we use
them they're actually doing much better
than if we just use leadership status as
a predictor of the centrality here
instead they're telling us and in fact I
won't go through it but it seems that
they're telling us they predict
centrality but they also are predicting
other things about individuals so
there's other attributes that
individuals have that might make them
good news spreaders that people are able
to incorporate into their answers to
these questions that we're not picking
up necessarily by just looking at the
social structure and our social
structure might not be the right one
we're using a very specific measurement
they might be doing even better than we
could and you can look at the you know
there's these distributions are strongly
different from each other in terms of
the statistical sense the p-values are
basically zeros for looking at the
difference in distributions across the
villages
okay so what that told us is here's a
problem we want to spread information
how do we do it and and people can tell
help tell us and we have some theory as
to why that works but it seems that
that's you know sort of one coherent
story of diffusion I want to just talk
very briefly this ties together a little
bit this isn't work with with each ink
Shing was a student at Stanford and what
we looked at was trying to understand
what people know about other people's
behaviors not just their social position
and in particular can they predict other
people better than then then random and
I think you know sort of thinking about
this I want to point out why do we worry
about this this goes back to a problem
we sort of put this in perspective think
about busing and that went on in the
1970s and various proposals to integrate
high schools so when you look at what
happened the idea was will build large
high schools and within those large high
schools if we can we build larger high
schools and and are combining
populations will be able to build
balanced high schools that are
integrated well when you actually go
into those high schools and look what
happens when they built large high
schools that were well balanced in terms
the better balance they were in terms of
the populations the more segregated they
turned up in terms of the friendships so
I've worked with Sergio Iranian Paulo
pin and we actually look inside those
high schools they turn tend to be highly
segregated so this is is a picture of
one of the high schools from the ad
health data set by race and you can
begin to see that there's very few
friendships across races in this in this
data set and so what happened was you
know they would build a large high
school and people then would
self-segregate and so part of what we
want to understand is why what you know
what drives people's instinct to connect
with other individuals there's a whole
series of reasons but one thing we
wanted to figure out was maybe this is
partly due to the fact that other people
who are very similar to me are
predictable I live in the same world
it's not only that can communicate with
them and it's we have shared cultural
values and norms but I can actually
predict how they're going to pay
behave and so what we did was we looked
at that we did this on Amazon Turk of we
collected data from us and Indian
population so it's fifty four percent us
forty six percent Indian population and
we had so the advantage of sort of
crowdsourcing and using Mechanical Turk
we could we use 1300 subjects then
referees said we're paying too little
too you know these are economists when
you're paying subjects on Mechanical
Turk you're paying them very low wages
so they said we don't believe your
results so we did an extra 80 at 10
times the stakes and basically the
results are identical so 15 minutes all
inclusive the earnings in the main part
of one to three dollars and we had we
had them you know pass some tests to
make sure that that they understood the
questions and weren't just dancing
randomly and then the ones that passed
the 1300 are the ones that passed and
then went on to the rest of the test so
you know we have an age distribution the
advantage of you're using Mechanical
Turk and so forth you have less control
over you observing your population but
you get a much wider population in terms
of their demographic characteristics so
you don't end up with these sort of
weird characteristics as Joe Henrik and
all umm call them we're not just getting
Western rich educated individuals from
from universities but we're actually
getting a richer population in terms of
the difference in you know we get
religious variation us actually mostly
non religious Christian is the main then
India it's mostly Hindu some Muslim and
Christian behave so we can look at you
know different demographics with this
size data and begin to figure out what
drives the behavior so let me just show
you the game they played very simple
game so it's basically a battle the
sexes game with a an extra option which
was an equal option so they could each
so they repaired in two individuals
actually they're individuals matched
against the randomly selected person
from the population they're going to
choose a color
and based on that then they're going to
get a payoff so the first is the role
players payoff second is the column
players payoff here there's three Nash
equilibria but it's set up so that
there's one sort of equal pay off but
that the the total is higher if they go
for an asymmetric one but the asymmetric
one advantages one player strongly and
then less there's less advantage for
another player so here you know the it's
it's hard to predict exactly how people
going to play but it could be the
cultural backgrounds in terms of
inequality or equality will drive people
to choose different things so it might
be that we sort of go for the equal
option because that seems focal to us or
it could be to say okay look I'm pretty
sure we're going to go for something
unequal who's going to win and we go
more head-to-head and what we did is we
also gave them a correlating device so I
we have the same results for for non
correlating devices but what we did was
we we also gave them a prompt where we
just said you and the other person that
you're matched with are in a room thats
painted either purple orange or green
okay so this would allow them with three
questions it's hard to know whether
they're going to coordinate well this
would allow them to coordinate so
theoretically first if you see purple
then you might think all the other
person's also saw that we're in a purple
room maybe we're going to play purple
and so forth okay so what what it looks
like so let's look at the green prompt
so the green prompt is the one that says
you're in a green room and this is what
happens from the US subjects when
they're prompted green this is what
happens for the Indian subjects when
they're prompted green so you can see
that there's a strong difference the US
subjects are going for the they actually
play green they go for the more equal
the Indian subjects were attending to go
more of them one for the one that was
advantageous to them some went
anticipating that for the lesson been
ages but fewer of 11 for the green so
you see a strong difference in these
populations the prompt was you're in a
green room that was all oh we just said
you're in a green room
and you're playing this game we didn't
tell them play green or anything like
that we just said you're in a green room
so the that that's how whatever you want
to interpret it it was just a prompt it
just said you're in a green room and
you're playing this game that's it it
was a yeah it was priming it was sort of
a way of priming green behavior okay so
let me just wrap up then so basically
the asymmetric prompt if you prompt for
a symmetric then you'll get the US
population to go more asymmetric but
they're still staying much more you know
they still stay with agreed much more
than the Indian population and you get
differences in terms of whether they go
for the you know whether they're
disadvantaged whether they go for the
high payoff for the low pay off and you
know these are all highly statistically
different across the populations and
interestingly when you ask them so now
let's ask them so we asked them what do
you predict the other person's going to
do and what do you predict they're going
to do if they're from India and what do
you predict they're going to do if
they're from the US and what you get is
the US population predicts that the
other people are actually going to
behave similarly whether they're in
India or the US which matches up with
the way that they're playing and the
Indian population thinks that either
population is going to play the same
regardless of whether they're Indian new
yes but they still think that they're
going to play like the indian population
plays so people are predicting that the
other populations going to play like
they do and they're not able to
distinguish the play and but they better
coordinate with their own population so
this might would be one thing of you
know why is there hopefully well I'm
good at predicting my own population I'm
lousy predicting the other population
and I do better when I player against my
own population so both populations got
higher payoffs playing with their own
population okay so broader messages you
know people may not be able to draw
their networks but they can coordinate
with similar others they can name site
highly Central individuals this how
actually helps us to solve a very
specific problem this might give us
insights into understanding a more
general problem and you know people can
easily learn these things even though
they don't know the specifics of the
networks around them so thank you very
much that's
way to place this stop